así que aquí tenemos la gráfica
igual gtx y tenemos un punto de
discontinuidad justo aquí en x igual a 7
y lo que queremos encontrar es el límite
cuando extiende a 7 deje de x
esencialmente lo que estoy diciendo es a
que se aproxima la función así la
entrada de la función a se aproxima a 7
así que veamos si la entrada de la
función se aproxima a 7 por valores que
sean menores que 7 por ejemplo si x es
igual a 3 g de x está por aquí gt4 está
por aquí que de 5 está por aquí que de 6
está por aquí lo cual parece ser un poco
menor que menos 1 g de 6.5 parece ser
cercano
- un medio g de 6.9 parece que está por
aquí que es un poquito menor que 0 g de
6.99 parece ser es mucho más cercano a 0
pero todavía no será así que parece que
nos vamos acercando al cero cuando x se
acerca al 7 pero ojo cuando nos
aproximamos a 7 en x la función se
aproxima a 0 pero no en el valor de 7
muy bien ahora veamos si esto también es
cierto para valores mayores que 7 por
ejemplo de 9 están alrededor de 6 de 8
es un poquito más que 27 7.5 es un
poquito más que uno que de 7.1 es un
poco más que cero ig de 7.01 es aún más
cercano a cero ig de 7.000 01 será más
cercano a 0 pero no será 0 y eso quiere
decir que de nuevo parece que nos
estamos aproximando a 0 cuando x se
aproxima a 7 por la derecha
es más grandes y esto es muy interesante
porque el límite cuando x tiende a 7 en
este caso es diferente a lo que vale la
función en x igual a 7 cuando ponemos 7
en la función cuando ponemos a 7 ene efe
la gráfica nos dice que el valor de la
función es igual a 3 eso quiere decir
que tenemos un punto de discontinuidad
el cual a veces llaman un punto de
discontinuidad removible y no voy a
entrar mucho en detalle pero esto toca
un poco la idea de cómo hacer la prueba
de continuidad si el límite al cual nos
estamos aproximando en nuestra función
no es el mismo valor que el valor actual
que toma nuestra función al evaluar esa
entrada entonces estamos hablando de una
discontinuidad